for years germany has struggled to
reconcile its colonial history in africa
one aspect of that is stolen cultural
artifacts such as the benin bronzes on
display at several german museums
now although the path has been cleared
for their return to nigeria with the
foreign aid
and culture ministers from both
countries signing an agreement at a
ceremony a short time ago the deal
formally recognizes the pieces as the
property of nigeria
at the center of the colonialism debate
in germany the benin bronzes
in 1897
british forces looted thousands of the
art treasures from the royal palace in
benin
modern day nigeria
many ended up in german museums
more than 400 are in berlin's humboldt
forum
a long battle over the looted art is now
ending both germany and nigeria have
declared nigeria the rightful owner of
the plagues and sculptures
the breakthrough means the objects can
return to their homeland
it's also a radical change in
perspective for germany's museums
what's bedoit it is
what does change of ownership mean
it means that we western museums in the
northern hemisphere cannot simply
determine the narrative of these benin
bronzes any longer
nigeria will decide which artworks will
return
the government wants to build a new
museum to house the bronzes
partly financed by germany so as museum
professionals it is important for us to
discuss on issues and areas
of collaboration so that we'll be able
to benefit
from this you know after the
repatriation
museums across europe are starting to
opt for collaboration after years of
confrontation
but the british museum has refused to
give back its 900 bronzes
the issue has also become a bigger
public debate in france
in germany negotiations are ongoing to
keep at least some of the works in the
country on permanent loan
for more i can talk to flourish chukwua
from lagos in nigeria uh flourish how is
this agreement between nigeria and
germany being received in the nigerian
capital
well a lot of people here in nigeria of
course celebrating this as a victory
finally what is considered as the
heritage of nigerian people of the
people from benin is coming back home
but of course there are also questions
about you know how are these artifacts
going to be
used or you know set up in such a way
that it benefits the nigerian people and
so that they are not looted again like
by by corruption you know taking back to
places that
people don't know so there are lots of
conversations around what the government
is actually going to do with these
looted items when they come back home
and also with the resources in case the
german government and the nigerian
government reach an agreement of like
loaning the artifacts to to to those
museums
explain to us a little bit about the
importance for nigerians of of germany
recognizing these artifacts as having
been stolen from nigeria
well as um miss analina berbock said in
that report it sets the narrative
straight it's um it basically
retells the story of what happened it's
not just about the artifacts being
stolen it's also the way they were
stolen the number of people that were
massacred that were killed and this is
it has been like a pain and a scar in
history for a lot of people from that
region from benin kingdom and if you
read if you check online you read people
i'm saying that i'm from a family of
bronzers and it's so satisfying to see
that finally the truth is being told
about how these bronzes got to europe
and so for a lot of people it's the
first step of healing a painful part of
their history and also you have to
recognize that these being in bronzes
are not just art and not just you know a
form of expression for the people here
many people use these sculptures as a
symbol of spirituality they feel like it
connects them to the after world to
their ancestors to their history so it's
a very very vital part of their identity
and so cutting them away in such manner
you know really really did a lot of
damage to
to to to people here and so recognizing
that this was done this you know
atrocity was committed is a first step
and a big step to healing for many
people
now that really brings home the the
importance and significance of this and
uh that the fact that lives had to be
lost
uh is so tragic flourish thank you very
much for filling us in from lagos there
you